our subject for today
from the inside out from the inside out
my help cometh from the lord which made
heaven on earth
he will not suffer thy foot to be moved
he that keepeth thee will not slumber
behold he that keepeth israel shall
neither slumber nor sleep
the lord is thy keeper the lord is thy
shade upon thy right hand
the sun shall not smite thee by day
nor the moon by night
the lord shall preserve thee from all
evil he shall preserve thy soul
the lord shall preserve thy going out
and thy coming in from this time forth
and even forevermore
i thank god again
and i cannot thank him enough for this
high high privilege he's given to me
which he sent me through your pastor
pastor divan to speak for him
and to his beloved people and to any
guest who may be connecting with us
right now
and i will try
my best
to speak the word as simply as i
possibly can you know loy tells us
there's power in simplicity
and i want to present it in such a way
that the little boys and the little
girls listening will understand and if
they understand everyone above them will
also understand the bible is a simple
book to understand when you know what
the basics are it is a simple book to
understand why do i say that because the
bible says the lord is not willing that
any should perish ii peter chapter three
verse nine
the bible also says in first timothy
chapter two verse four god will have all
people to be saved and he wants all
people to come to a knowledge of the
truth if god wants all people to come to
a knowledge of the truth
and most people are not highly educated
then the truth
must be easy and simple to understand
and so i will try by god's grace to make
the message as simple as i possibly can
i welcome those of you wherever you are
in whatever country particularly the
host country of india thank you very
much for your interest in the word of
god it is an interest that will pay
dividends because god created the
universe by his word he saves by his
word he raised lazarus by his word he
cast out demons by his word he forgives
sins by his word he does everything by
his word the bible tells us in psalm 138
verse 2 he has magnified his word above
all his name and so by making time for
god's word you are making time for all
the power of god and ultimately and at
the highest level the person who makes
time for god's word is making time for
jesus christ because the bible says in
the beginning was the word
and the word was with god and the word
was god
the same was in the beginning with god
all things were made by him and without
him was not anything made that was made
who is this him who is this word verse
10 of john 1 he was in the world and the
world was made by him and the world knew
him not verse 11 he came unto his own
and his own received him not who is that
jesus christ verse 14 and the word
became flesh by making time for the word
of god you are making time for christ
and for god
let me turn that coin over
when we have no time for god's word
we are effectively saying we have no
time for god
let me say differently
to deny the word is to deny the savior
and so god bless you
for making time for his word
i welcome always in a special way the
little boys and the little girls who
listening wherever you are seated on the
couch next to your parents next to your
friends
thank you for loving jesus
jesus i want him to bless you and bless
you so that you grow up to be strong men
and strong women for jesus
our subject for today
from the inside out from the inside out
that's our message for today before i
get into that message let me ask you as
always preserve reverence where you are
i've said before and i suppose i'll say
it as long as we have all these
electronic methods of connecting one to
the other
zoom
youtube
facebook you name it these things do not
reduce the holiness of god they do not
make god a secular god we may be using a
secular technology but we're worshiping
a holy god and so wherever you are
give god reverence he deserves that and
he wants it
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
i make that request all the time and
every time i make it i'm very very
serious
it is easy you see even though a person
is a christian
the person still has the carnal nature
and the bible says in galatians 5 17 the
flesh lusteth against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh in other words
there's a constant battle even in the
believer especially in the believer
because of that i want god to put his
words in my mouth or the enemy may put
the wrong word in my mouth
jeremiah 1 verse 9 then the lord put
forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth those are the
words that i want to speak so please ask
god from time to time put your words in
that man's mouth
and favor number three
think
as you listen
concentrate do not allow anyone to
disturb you concentrate because
ultimately and at the very foundation a
relationship with christ is an
individual matter concentrate think
isaiah 1 18 come now
let us reason god is inviting he's
appealing he's almost begging us come to
me says god let's reason together why do
you no longer come to church come on
says god let's talk about that why do
you disrespect your parents come on says
god let's talk about that why do you do
this or that let's reason together says
god i will listen to you as you give me
your reasons then i will give you the
light of truth the way i will have you
to go let's reason together said the
lord let's pray
dear god
thank you for life
thank you father for this
technology
that allows us to worship this way
that allows me to enter india and any
other country represented by those
listening i can enter those countries
without documents without passports we
thank you for this technology
we thank you thank god for all those
listening we thank you for the interest
they have in spiritual things
i ask you father quickly if we've sinned
against you particularly me forgive us
their god forgive us
that's why jesus died and rose to make
forgiveness possible and available
grant to mean a special way your holy
spirit of truth the bible says in john
16 13
i'll be it
when he the spirit of truth is come he
will guide you into all truth father let
your spirit absolutely possess my mind i
give him permission
and with that control let him guide me
into truth that i may guide your people
into truth
send angels to protect us wherever we
are that we may worship you without
hindrance without interference
father bless the little boys the little
girls in a very very special way remind
them constantly that you love them and
you want them to give their lives to you
i believe there are people listening to
god who will not sever the adventists we
thank you and we're honored by their
presence bless them in such a way that
we would they will always desire to
fellowship with the set of the adventist
people father this every country
represented by the audience father bless
anyone who has the covet 19 heal that
person father please
and in a wider general way place your
hand of mercy upon anyone listening who
is sick regardless of the nature of the
sickness touch that person and bring if
not total healing bring relief i pray
now father bless the leaders of all the
countries
represented by those listening
particularly the host country the lovely
country of india
guide the minds of the leaders father
remind them that the most high ruleless
in the kingdoms of men
reminds of their god that righteousness
exalted the nation remind the union
leaders and the conference leaders the
division leaders the church leaders that
righteousness exalted the church exalted
the union exalted the conference exalted
the individual
speak through me now dear god
in jesus name i pray
amen
ecclesiastes 12
reading from verse 11.
ecclesiastes 12 reading from verse 11
verse 13 sorry ecclesiastes 12 reading
from verse 13.
the bible says
let us hear the conclusion
of the whole matter
fear god
and keep his commandments
for this
is the whole
duty of man
we read that again
microscopically
let us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter solomon is writing at the end of
his life
he was faithful to god at the beginning
of his life his reign he drifted from
god went off into the world by his
behavior his thinking his attitude he
comes back to god now he looks back over
his life the wisest man who ever lived
who made the most stupid mistakes anyone
could ever make it's amazing how that
can happen he now tells us drawing from
his vast reservoir of experience
let us hear the conclusion
of the whole matter this is what life
comes down to
fear god meaning recognize who god is
and keep his commandments
fearing god
a genuine fear of god produces obedience
to god let me say it again a genuine
fear of god
produces obedience to god and so when we
really fear god and keep his
commandments they're not as separate as
we may think they are linked it's like
love and obedience you cannot separate
them faith and work they sound different
but they are inseparable because where
there's no faith no works the faith is
dead where there's no obedience there is
no love where there's no obedience there
is no fear fear god
and keep his commandments
so this is the whole duty of man
now
where has god placed his commandments
when he gave the lord moses he placed
the law on tables of stone
god has always desired his law to be
placed on the inside
in the heart
not on table stone
not on the forehead not on the wrist
in the heart of a person that's where
god has always wanted his law long
before we read about what's called the
new covenant which is the only covenant
by the way by which anyone can be saved
he wants the law written in the heart of
a person now which means that god
desires to function and to operate from
the inside out
the whole duty of man mankind
flows from the inside out it is placed
on the inside then it is expressed and
what is that the law of god the ten
commandments of god
having established that
that god wants to put his law in our
hearts that's where he puts it i want
you now to consider ephesians chapter 2
verse 14
our subject from the inside out
ephesians chapter 2 reading verse 14.
listen very carefully to what the bible
says
for he is our peace
who have made both one and have broken
down the middle wall of petition
having abolished his flesh the enmity
now he
is our peace
the verse does not say
jesus has peace
the bible says he is peace
and he is our peace
if you keep this in mind and you read
the words of christ in john 14 27
peace
i give i leave with you peace i give
unto you not as the world giveth give i
unto you what does it mean by that
the only way to have the peace of christ
is to have christ
ephesians 2 14 he is our peace
from the inside out is our subject for
that peace to function it must function
from the inside out when god said let us
make man in our image the image begins
from the inside and is expressed on the
outside the principle by which god
functions to direct the life to change
the life to preserve the life is from
the inside out
you can buy a bottle of alcohol
and put it on your dining table
and look at it
24 hours a day
you will never get drunk
because it is on the outside
it's not on the inside
let me say it again you may look at a
bottle of alcohol
hours a day without blinking it will not
make you drunk even if you hold it in
your hand and bring it up to your face
and put it on the inside pocket of your
coat it will not make you drunk because
it is not inside now if you open that
bottle and you drink the content and
they get into you now the way you speak
changes your eyesight changes you the
way you walk change everything changes
because it is now functioning from the
inside out there are many of us
we have the bible on the shelf
there's one behind me
it is not on the inside
and so it does not produce the desired
effects because the power of scripture
does not function on a shelf
it functions when it is put into the
heart of a person and the scripture
ultimately is jesus christ as i said
earlier he is the word
our subject is from the inside out let
me pray again father in heaven be with
me as i try by your grace and your
spirit to make this message as simple as
i can in jesus name i pray amen from the
inside out he is our peace
ephesians 2 14
let's see what else he is to us
go to first corinthians chapter 1
we read verse 30. first corinthians
chapter 1 reading verse 30 our subject
from the inside out
but of him are he in christ jesus who of
god is made unto us wisdom and
redemption and wisdom and righteousness
sanctification and redemption now he is
made unto us
wisdom
righteousness sanctification
redemption
that's what he is to us
but of him which is god
are he in christ jesus who of god is
made unto us by god's arrangement then
christ is to us wisdom
not simply he has wisdom he is wisdom
he is redemption he is sanctification he
is righteousness as verily as he is
peace
in ephesians 2
verse 14.
let's go to john chapter 15.
you read verse one
john 15
verse 1
our subject
from the inside up
the bible says this is christ himself
speaking i am the true fight
i am
not i have i am the true vine which
means to which we to whom we must be
connected i am the true fight he is our
peace he is our wisdom he is our
righteousness he is our sanctification
he is
our everything our redemption
i am
the true vine that's what jesus says
let's go to john 6.
read verse 51
john 6
the bible says i am the living bread
which came down from heaven i
am the living brain not i have bread i
am bread
i am peace
i am divine
i am wisdom redemption sanctification
righteousness i am the living bread and
where does god want to be on the inside
let's go to john 8.
let's read verse 12
you have the bible with the red letters
the words of jesus i am the light of the
world i
am the light of the world so jesus is
all these things of course when moses
told god which was christ in exodus 3
verse 13 behold
exodus 3 13 behold when i come unto the
children of israel and shall say to them
the god of your fathers have sent me
unto you and they shall say unto me what
is his name what shall i say to them and
what was the name that god gave to moses
i am that i am i am not i have i am i am
life i am existence i am power i am love
i am i am
and so jesus is peace
he is wisdom he is righteousness he is
but wisdom is useless if he simply stays
in a book on the shelves are you with me
now
having said all of that you know jesus i
am the door
i am the shepherd he's all these things
let me tell you something else jesus is
jesus
is the law
let me say it again jesus
as verily as he is peace
as verily as he is love
has ver because the law is love and
jesus is love the bible says god is love
first john chapter 4 verse 8 he that
loveth not know if not god for god is
love if god is loved and the bible says
love is the fulfillment of the law then
jesus christ is the law
let's get some help from someone who
received direct inspiration from god
christ triumphs on page 339 paragraph
two
christ triumphant page 339
paragraph two
i hope you write these references down
here is what the servant of the lord
ella white tells us and i hope you make
time to read the writings of god's
servant you'll be greatly blessed christ
came to our world to reveal to represent
the character of god as it is
represented in his holy law so his law
is a transcript of his character
listen to how that quotation ends
christ was both the law and the gospel
christ was the law he still is and the
gospel he
was the gospel he was and is the law she
writes christ was the law let me say
differently if you were to put feet on
the law and hands and a face and fingers
and a nose and ears what would you have
jesus
in other words jesus is the living law
jesus is peace living jesus is love
alive jesus is living bread jesus is the
living fine jesus is delivering
everything he says he is i am the word
he's the living word he tells us in john
14 6 i am the way i am the truth i am
the life not i have the way i have the
truth i have the life even though all of
that is correct but at a deeper level
and a higher level on a wider level i am
the way
i am the truth i am the life which means
you cannot get around the fact that it
is jesus and jesus alone but he must be
on the inside
he does not work from the outside he
works from the inside and so god says i
will put my law in the inward parts and
write them in their hearts that's what
god wants to do because he functions
from the inside out in ezekiel 36 26
ezekiel 36 26 a new heart also will i
give you any new spirit will i put
within you
christ is not a cream you rub
on the skin but matter of fact if you
want nice skin don't buy creams change
your diet are you with me change your
diet it works from the inside out drink
more water change your diet and your
skin will change putting on cream does
not give you good skin what you put
inside of you it could purify your skin
but it functions from the inside out now
what have we said so far we've said that
the whole duty of man
is the fair god and you cannot fear god
truly without obeying god because the
obedience is the expression of the fear
of god and fear of god is not fear of
rattlesnake it means an awe a reference
for god because you understand who he is
and so obedience and fear cannot be
separated the whole duty of you
listening to me is to fear god
and keep his commandments where does god
put the commandments in the heart in
your heart is where he wants to put it
because it must function from the inside
out jesus the bible tells us in ezekiel
36 26 a new heart also will i give you
and a new spirit will i put within you
when christ cast out demons he did not
cast out demons from people's pockets he
cast them out from the inside out
because even the demons they function
from the inside out very much the way
christ functions from the inside out
whether satan or christ it is from the
inside out so we have to be careful what
we put on the inside and i'm telling you
put christ because when christ is on the
inside what do you have you have peace
john 14 27 the world gives a kind of
peace but that peace only lasts when
everything goes well the peace of christ
remains even in a storm when you have
christ you have peace
you have love
you have you have the living bread you
have the word you have the truth you
have the way you have the life you have
divinity within you without making you
god let me say that you have
if christ dwells within you divinity
dwells within you think of that
not a piece of stone something carved
from a rock of his wood when you have
christ within you you have divinity
within you the same way christ in his
human form had his father within him you
and i must have christ within us it is
christ in you the hope of glory paul
says in galatians 2 20 i am crucified
with christ
nevertheless i lived yet not i but
christ lives in me who is living in paul
christ the creator christ the redeemer
christ who's equal with the father
christ the commander of the angels he is
the one who indwells us i say again when
you have christ you have divinity
dwelling within your divinity
without making you god
you have god within divinity christ in
you the hope of glory
christ is the law which is something i
want to stress today christ is the law
to get rid of the law
is to get rid of christ
let me say it again to get rid of the
law
is to get rid of christ
to get rid of love is to get rid of
christ
to get rid of heavenly peace is to get
rid of christ because he's everything
christ
is the law
in our hearts now let's go to john
19. see something very interesting let
me pray again father be with me as i
continue to minister
for your glory and to your people in
jesus name i pray amen
john 19
we read for verse 5
our subject from the inside out
let me check the time
five minutes to ten where i am
and in the morning that is john 19
reading from verse five the bible says
then came jesus forth wearing the crown
of thorns and the purple robe and pilot
said unto them
behold the man
when the chief priest therefore an
officer saw him they cried out saying
crucify him crucify him in other words
kill god and by the way
just in case you're looking down on the
pharisees and scribes in many ways you
and i say kill god
by the way we behave and live our lives
we're saying kill god so don't look down
on those people 2 000 years ago the
carnal nature is the carnal nature from
adam until now
they cried out saying crucify him
crucify him pilate said unto them take
ye him and crucify him for i find no
fault in him
listen to what the jews say in verse
seven
the jews answered him
they said to pilate
we have a law
and by our law
he ought to die
because he made himself the son of god
they said we have a law
and by our law he ought to die what am i
trying to get you to see
the jews were trying to use the law
to kill christ
let me say it again
the jews tried to use the law
to kill christ
we have a law
and by our law he ought to die
so the law was presented as an
instrument to kill the law giver himself
now
let's fast forward 2 000 years we come
to the modern times here is what people
do go to colossians chapter 2 let's read
from verse 14 colossians 2 from verse 14
are subject from the inside out
colossians written by the apostle paul
very similar to ephesians colossians and
ephesians much of the information is in
both books
colossians chapter 2 from verse 14
listen carefully blotting out the
handwriting of ordinances that was
contrary to us which was against us he
took it out of the way nailing it to his
cross
christians use that verse to say christ
crucified the law
two thousand years ago the jew said we
have our law and by our law he ought to
die the jews tried to use the law to
kill christ today we try to use christ
to kill the law
and so people say when christ died he
crucified the law he nailed the laws of
the cross and they're referring to the
ten commandments which christ did not do
at all because the same jesus
tells us in revelation 22 14 blessed are
they that do his commandments and we
know from chapter one of revelation that
came from god the father to jesus to the
angel to john to the churches and so
revelation 22 14 ultimately came from
the father given to christ christ to the
angel the angel to john john to us
blotting out the handwriting of all this
that was against us which was contrary
to us he took it out of the way nailing
it to the cross and christians jump on
that not adventist christians jump on
that to say look
jesus crucified the law we no longer
have to keep the law two thousand years
ago they said kill him we no longer have
to deal with him today people say kill
the law we no longer have to keep it
if you kill the law
you kill christ
getting rid of the law
is getting rid of christ
and i i'm trying to get you my friend to
understand this this is not legalism as
i told i think it was yesterday or the
day before it is not keeping a lot of
saves you it is christ the savior but
christ saves you to bring you into
harmony and conformity with the standard
of the law and that standard is the
character of god himself patriots and
prophets page 52
paragraph 3
the law is as sacred as god himself let
me say that again the law of god is as
sacred as god himself the law of god is
a divine standard and to get rid of it
is tantamount to getting rid of god or
trying because no one can get rid of god
no one can get rid of god's law because
the entire universe runs on law but god
wants the same law that guides the
universe to be placed in your heart and
in mind
let me say that again
there's a little engine that runs a
lawnmower
and sometimes my
my lawn has to be mowed in the same
spring and the summer when the grass
grows and grows there's a little engine
that runs a lawn mower there's a little
engine that runs what is called the
garbage disposal which we have the
united states it's in the sink in the
kitchen you put some things down there
the thing spins incinerates and thing
just goes out of the house now
that little engine cannot operate a
spaceship
the little engine in a lawn mower the
little whatever makes a shaving thing go
it cannot run
a spaceship
or aircraft carrier or jumbo jet
let's reverse that
the law that governs the entire universe
god takes that same law and puts it in
your heart to run your life
let me say it differently
in the sanctuary the law was placed in
the ark the ark represented the seed of
god the throne of god because right
above the ark above the mercy was what
is called the shekinah a light
representing the presence of god and god
said from here i will tell you
everything i have to tell you exodus 25
verse 22 the the ark representing the
throne of god and in that ark was the
law which tells us the universal kingdom
of god is based on law because without
law you cannot have a government
patriotism prophet's page 49 paragraph 1
god placed man under law
as an indispensable condition of his
very existence he was made a subject of
the divine government and there can be
no government without law
that law that is the basis of universal
functioning
is placed
in your heart and in mind
that law which reflects the very
character of god the very righteousness
of god the very sacredness of god that
law is placed in your heart and mind
when we allow god to do it
and a person
is his character or her character that's
who we are i am my character you are
your character the law is the character
of god the law is life christ dwells in
our hearts when his law dwells in our
hearts why because as fairly as he is
the bread as verily as he is the light
as verily as he is the door and he is
the the sacrificial lamb and he's the
true vine he is the law he is the gospel
so when the law is written in the heart
jesus christ is in the heart
let me tell you something else about
that go to second corinthians chapter
three let's read verse three
ii corinthians verse three chapter 3
verse 3 our subject from the inside out
let me pray again father continue to
speak through me god and restrain my
carnal nature i pray that your spirit
may have his way uninterruptedly in
jesus name i pray amen second
corinthians 3
for as much as he manifestly declared to
be an epistle of christ written by us
not with ink
but with the spirit of living god not in
tables of stone but in fleshy tables of
the heart in other words the verse is
telling us that the spirit
that wrote the law on stone
writes the law in our hearts
listen to the verse again for as much as
you manifestly declared to be the
episodes of christ meaning each
christian is like a little letter that
people read by the way we live our lives
ministered by us written not within but
with the spirit of the living god not on
tables of stone but on fleshy tables of
the heart the spirit of god
is the one who writes the law in the
heart it is through the spirit that
jesus christ dwells in the heart it is
through the spirit that the living law
jesus christ dwells within us
as verily as that logs on stone so
fairly is it written in the heart and it
is written there by placing christ there
through the ministry of the spirit of
god
inside out
you're not a christian by the time you
wear even though you should wear one if
that's your custom you're not a
christian like what's your suit even
though you just probably to worship god
by the shoes you wear the socks you wear
the car you drive it is the presence of
the living law in the heart that makes a
person a christian and that living lord
is jesus and jesus
is the law and it functions from the
inside out
elohim writes in bible commentary volume
pages 675 paragraph 7 1075 paragraph 7
bible commentary volume 6 page 1075
paragraph 7.
the new birth
is a rare experience in this age of the
world
this is the reason why there are so many
perplexities in the churches many so
many who assume the name of christ are
unsanctified and unholy they were
baptized but they were buried alive
shells did not die and so they did not
rise the newness of life in christ bible
commentary volume 6 page 1075 paragraph
no change took place on the inside
getting the skin wet does not bring
about a change it is the application of
the living water the living bread the
living lord inside that makes a person a
child of god and so solomon said let us
hear the conclusion
of the whole
matter fear god
and keep his commandments i can say that
differently fear god
and live like him
fear god
that's what obedience produces the life
of god in a human being i say it again
the life of god in a human being
but it works
from the inside out and so i called upon
you in the name of jesus the living law
the jews tried to kill him using the law
today we use christ to kill the law the
jews said we have the law by our law he
ought to die today we said christ nailed
the law to the cross
where do you kill christ you kill the
law it is the same thing because jesus
christ is the law jesus christ is the
gospel when you obey the commandments of
god you are simply living the life of
christ or let me say differently you're
simply allowing christ to live his life
out of you as paul said i am crucified
with christ nevertheless i live yet not
i but christ liveth in me listen to what
jesus himself said in john 14 let's read
from verse 8 of john 14 let me pray
again father as i come to the close
continue to be with me i pray in jesus
name amen john 14 reading from verse 8
philip says unto him lord show us the
father and it sufficeth us
jesus said unto him have i been so long
time with you and yet hast thou not
known me philip he that have seen me
have seen the father and how says thou
then shows the father believers thou not
that i am in the father and the father
in me
it's an intermingling i am in the father
and the father in me that's the way it
must be with us in christ we in christ
christ on us the words that i speak unto
you i speak not of myself but the father
that dwelleth in me he do with the works
what am i trying to tell you
everything christ did
was the father working through him
whatever christ said
it was the father speaking through him
paul says
nevertheless i live yet not i but christ
liveth in me or christ lives through me
he lives his life out of me
this is god's desire
to dwell in us
and express his life through us
jesus christ
the living law desires to abide in your
heart
from there
he expresses his life
with your constant permission every day
we surrender again to christ our high
calling page 215 paragraph two
genuine conversion is needed not once in
years but daily
i say that again genuine conversion is
needed not once in years but daily and
as we daily surrender to christ
we constantly give him permission
to do with us as he will and the eternal
dwelling of christ is the power we need
to say yes to righteousness and notice
sin
from the inside out my brothers and
sisters
the jews try to use the law to kill
christ
modern christians tries to use christ to
kill the law both
fail and will always fail if you kill
the law you have killed christ if you
kill christ you've killed the law why
because christ
is the living law as verily as he is the
way
the truth the life the light the bread
the vine she is
the living law that which governs the
entire universe as i said god wants to
take the unit the law that governs the
entire universe and place it in your
heart to guide and govern your little
world let us pray father in heaven
we thank you so much for your word
we thank you thank god for the almost
impossible reality almost i see
difficult for us to understand but we
should believe
that the powerful god
that not even the universe can contain
wants to dwell in us
we thank you that christ is the living
law and that law is written with the
living word on our hearts so that when
the law is within us christ has within
us
our father help us to understand that
alcohol in a bottle on the table
cannot make someone drunk the person has
to take it in let us take christ in
and how do we do that dear god we take
his living word because he is the word
when we receive the word we receive
christ your servant elohim tells us in
the desire of ages page 67 paragraph one
it is through the word that christ
abides in his followers and the word
condensed
comes down to the law of god the ten
commandments the expression of the
righteousness of god please the god help
us to renew our surrender to christ
right now to ask him to come in again or
to stay in and to go even deeper into
our souls so that what we say becomes
the words of christ what we think
becomes his thoughts what we do become
his actions because it is he living in
us and out of us
bless everyone who listened heal the
sickness god guide the little boys and
girls and the double blessing and all
our guests bless the working india in a
very special way because india is the
host country for this program but bless
other countries that are connecting
father we thank you for freedom of
worship help us to do all we can now
that we have this freedom because one
day it will cease keep us faithful today
save us when you come in jesus name we
pray amen
you